All right. So, I wanted to do this video
a while ago when the wrath runes were
actually released with the Dragon Slayer
2 update. But back then, wrath runes
were going for like 500 and 600 each,
and this method was actually just too
costly for it to be viable. But now,
since they're hovering at around 400
each, I think that this can actually be
really, really good. If you guys haven't
already looked at the title, what we're
going to be doing today is we are going
to be killing lava dragons with the new
best fire spell, fire surge. It's
actually the last spell on the
spellbook, and it requires a 95 magic.
We only have 94 but we're just going to
pot up and then we're going to use
preserve so that we can cast the spell.
As for the inventory, we've got the
pestle and mortar, the looting bag to
collect the loot, and an occult teleport
so that we can get there quickly, a
prayer potion, a magic potion, a wrath
runes, and just a few food in case we
get hit by the dragon. If we stumble
across a PKer, we're pretty much dead if
they have freezes cuz we do not have the
agility shortcut. Now, this is the gear.
This is the more important stuff. To get
the max hit, what we're using is the
tome of fire, the occult necklace, the
mystic smoke staff, and the tormented
bracelet. We also have a wealth so we
can teleport at 30 wild. You have the
standard major arena cape. I do not have
the new cape. I'm probably going to get
that in the future, and then we just
have the black mystic boots and just a
random robes that I picked out of my
bank. We've already got the timer on the
screen, guys. So, what I'm going to do
is go ahead and start that right now,
and we're just going to break the occult
teleport.
I just saw someone there, so we
instantly just logged out. Oh my god,
let's hop worlds. All right. Luckily, we
didn't die right off the bat there.
We're just going to go ahead and mage
pot right now. We're going to put the
preserve prayer on and get that fire
surge on auto cast. Apparently, this
thing is nuts. We can hit 46 if I'm not
wrong.
We're going to be killing them right
here in the middle because we're going
to be getting kills so fast that we're
going to need more than one. So, we're
just going to go ahead and start. See
how fast this first kill takes.
Yeah, that took like 20 seconds. Pretty
freaking nuts. And we got chocolate
cake, which isn't the best drop. By the
way, if you're confused that why I'm
able to cast this with only wrath runes,
the Tome of Fire gives unlimited fire
runes, and the mystic smoke staff
actually gives unlimited air and fire
runes. Remember that if you're doing
this, always have the log out button at
the ready because there are so many
PKers here. And there's a 45. Holy into
a 43.
Into a 34. We're going to like five hit
this one.
But yeah, with the lava scales, we're
just going to use them with the pestle
and mortar to get lava shards. If you
guys are wondering, by the way, this is
like 80K magic XP per hour. So, it's
actually not even bad XP. But yeah, this
inventory is going to be really, really
quick. We've already gotten four kills.
The looting bag is at 38K. If you want
to be efficient, you can loot the pile
of the other while attacking the other
spawn.
That way you can get the most kills per
hour. And we just got onyx bolt tips, by
the way, which is like a 100K drop.
Yeah, we have to be really careful now
because we actually have some really
good loot on us. This kill number six
coming in.
What are we going to get?
Fire orbs, nice. That's like 20K alone.
Oh my god, we got a random event. And I
thought that was someone logging right
into me. We are just absolutely
demolishing these. Holy I just
looted the other one, and now this one's
almost dead.
Another kill coming in. We get the rune
knight bar, nice. That's rare drop
table, I think.
Solid drop. Now, if you guys want to
make the most profit, flicking a mage
prayer might not be the worst of ideas
because I do splash like one in maybe 12
times. And that does suck like right
there because it does cost a rune. You
know, it's not the end of the world, but
like after an hour, you know, it does
make a diff- Now, if If nuts, what you
can bring are alchs because you guys can
see I have a few alch bows on me right
now. I also put the addy plate body in
the looting bag. We could have alched it
for cash, which is stackable, saves
inventory spots, and there's a random HP
level. All right, 104 combat. God damn
it. Now we have to max another onyx bolt
tip drop. Holy, the RNG is real right
now. If we die, I'm going to be so sad.
All right, we just ran out of wrath
runes, so we definitely have to bring
more next trip. All right, nice. We got
out alive. We're back at the granite
Just going to make a separate tab
for all the loot here.
If you're here, make sure you close the
gate behind you. It's actually a good
idea to do that because if a PKer came
here and they saw an open gate, they
could guess that you were killing the
dragons and it could be a dead giveaway.
Oh, we've got a PKer over there.
He's across the wall. I think it was a
pure though. I don't think he can attack
me.
Yep, there he is. Oh my woo. All right.
I should have hopped earlier.
Um we have to pick a world now. Jesus
Christ, that was actually a really close
call. Thank god I moved all the way back
here so he couldn't attack me from over
the the lava there. We're just going to
brush that aside and just continue as
normal. No big deal.
Nice. Holy crap, that dragon just got
absolutely destroyed. No, like
seriously, that was like a four hit.
Oh that's a PKer. Oh my god. Oh my
god, please.
Holy we are so lucky. I was in
combat with the dragon so I couldn't log
out right away. All right, we're going
to hop to one of the Australian worlds
right now.
Okay, is that a PKer? No, that is not a
PKer. Someone killing dragons. He
instantly logged out though.
Oh yeah, something I didn't actually
mention earlier. When you're out here
with this type of risk, if you get
skulled,
uh you're losing like a good 3 mil. And
if you have a code I want, you don't
want to accidentally skull because if
they have dragon spears, they can smite
you out and uh yeah, that would not be a
good time. Make sure your left click is
actually hidden. You do not want to
accidentally skull.
If you guys want an absolute pro tip, if
you get the blood rune or death rune
drop, use a lower tier spell if the
dragon is at a lower HP. That way you
don't waste the wrath rune and that way
you make more profit per hour. So, uh
yeah.
All right, second trip in. Another full
looting bag. Just a full bones and
dehy's. Haven't really gotten too lucky.
Damn, this trip is actually ridiculous.
Every single drop seems to just be
either rune knives, rune javelins, or
rune bows. I've left so many rune
javelins on the ground. Yeah, this is
really, really good mage EXP. Some may
argue that you could just bring a toxic
trident, but um yeah, this is really,
really nice mage EXP. So, if you want a
mage training method and you want to
make some profit, this is actually
really, really good. Yes, another onyx
bolt tip drop. That's three so far.
If we can get four, that would be
absolutely amazing. That'd be 400k from
just onyx bolt tip drops. But as you see
like right here, it's not worth me using
a wrath rune. Rather just use fire wave
and uh KO it instead of wasting it.
To be honest, I thought there would be a
lot more PKers. We only saw two
different PKers. It's pretty busy at
this time on the game. I don't really
know what's going on. Maybe there's just
no people doing lava dragons. I'm like
the only one. And I mean right now we're
getting 95k EXP per hour in magic.
Like I thought we were going to level up
this video,
but I think I'd have to do it for like
another 30 minutes afterwards.
Oh my god, that guy scared the absolute
out of me. I still logged out. I
think we're just going to log back in. I
think that guy was just doing a clue.
I think we're safe.
Oh yeah, by the way, if you didn't know
this, when you have the ring of wealth
equipped, you can actually toggle coin
collection, which basically picks up the
coins automatically that monsters drop.
And they actually added up really nicely
here. Look, we've got 9,000 GP in just
coin drops this trip.
Oh my god, PKer, PKer. What even was
that? No, how am I in combat? Oh, I
wasn't in combat. What? I got the thing
in the chat box cuz the dragon hit me.
Oh my god, dude. No, that gave me a
heart attack, dude. Oh my god. Nice,
there it is. Last kill, full inventory.
And we got runite bolts. That's fine.
You're kidding me. Okay, this dwarf
attacked me so I couldn't log out, and I
thought that was a guy with like
barrage. I have no food. We would have
been dead. Oh my god, please. Let's get
out of here.
Oh my god, flawless again. No death.
Let's bank all of this. That was a That
was a solid inventory.
All right, this is the same world.
Someone's using my salamander tactic to
kill them. Onyx bolt tips again, guys.
That's the fourth one.
Can't tell if lucky or, you know, that's
normal cuz I haven't done lava dragons
enough. Oh god, that is a PKer.
I think I've dodged that guy like three
times. And
boom, there it is. The 1-hour, nicely
done. That is the bank tab, guys. We got
62 kills in the hour, which is really,
really good. Now, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to pull everything out of
the bank that we received as a drop into
my inventory.
All right, everything we've acquired
from the lava dragons in 1 hour is now
in our inventory. We're going to pop it
onto the price checker. 1.1 mil, almost
1.2 mil. Now, we cannot forget one thing
though, it did not come for free. This
was not budget lava dragons. This was
wrath rune lava dragons. As you guys can
see, we bought the wrath runes for 400
each. And 742 wrath runes at 400 each is
pretty much 300k. So, we made around
800k profit, which is still really,
really, really good.
And there it is, guys. 1.1 mil in 4k.
But yeah, guys, not only did we make
800k profit, we we also got 82k mage
exp, which is really, really good.
I'm actually really happy with the
result. We didn't die once, as well,
because we were on that logout button.
But yeah, let's go give away some of the
profit. I don't know what it is, but a
lot of people said that I should go to
the hill giants when doing this and
giving away the money. So, that's
exactly what I'm going to do. I'm going
to give three people 200k. Garthanax,
what's going on? You got the addy plate.
You got to do dragon slayer two, my man.
But here you go, take this, and I hope,
you know, this does you well.
I just feel like giving all these people
200k.
Thanks. Exclamation mark. No problem,
man. Oh my god, look at this guy. The
full addy rip is so nice.
It actually just looks nice. Here you
go, man.
Hope you can upgrade to full rune soon.
Uh I think he's just 30 defense, though,
that's why. Oh my god. Betty Kiss 1919,
what are you doing? You're training with
a maple longbow. Take my bank.
No, but honestly, I love seeing players
like this training with the maple
longbow. But uh yeah, the result of
using the new spell, fire surge, at lava
dragons actually turned out to be
really, really, really, really good and
I hope you guys do it if you want some
beastly magic XP and you want to make
profit while doing it. And uh yeah, I
don't really have much more to say. So,
until next time, guys.